مسدس الدعامة عبارة عن مصطلح غريب نوعًا ما
في صناعة السينما والتلفزيون ، فهم
يستخدمون مجموعة متنوعة من الأسلحة المختلفة
بدءًا من
سلاح ناري مزيف تمامًا
تم تصنيعه بحيث لا يمكن إطلاق شيء مطاطي أو خشب
لا يمكن إطلاقه مطلقًا  ولكن يبدو
وكأنه مسدس ،
فلديك سلاح ناري معطل وهو مسدس
اعتاد أن يكون مسدسًا تم
جعله غير قادر على إطلاق النار ومن
ثم لديك بندقية حقيقية في الطرف الآخر
من الطيف عندما نتحدث
حول إطلاق الفراغات في مكان التصوير ،
عادةً ما يكون ذلك باستخدام مسدس حقيقي ، فهناك
زوجان من الأسلحة
المصممة فقط لإطلاق الفراغات ولكن
معظم الأسلحة المستخدمة في المجموعة ليست بنادق حقيقية
تطلق طلقات
سوداء بجولة فارغة لديك كل
شيء  عادة ما يكون لديك جولة حقيقية
ولكن ليس لديك الرصاصة
في نهايتها ، لذلك عندما تشتعل
تحصل على الوميض
تحصل على الارتداد تحصل على الانفجار
ولكنك لا تحصل على  رصاصة تطير
من نهاية البندقية وهذا لا يحدث  يعني
أن الجولات الفارغة آمنة لأنه إذا
كنت ستعترض طريق ذلك أو
اقتربت منه كثيرًا ويمكن التخلص من الكثير من الأوساخ
والحطام من نهاية
البندقية التي يمكن أن تسبب ضررًا ،
فمن النادر جدًا حدوث ذلك و  من
النادر أيضًا أن يتسبب ذلك في الموت
[موسيقى]
من حيث الاستعداد له أولاً ،
فأنت تريد التأكد من أن الممثل
مرتاح للسلاح الناري ،
لذا قم بتدريب الممثل حتى يعرف
ما هو آمن وما هو غير ذلك
بمجرد تسليمك  المسدس لهم ،
إنهم سعداء أيضًا
بمساعدة المخرج وأي شخص آخر معني في
إعداد اللقطة وإعداد المشهد
بحيث يكون آمنًا قدر الإمكان ،
فهناك طرق يمكنك من خلالها خداع الزوايا وخداع
الأشياء حتى لا يوجه أحد بندقيتك
مباشرة إلى شخص ما ،
لذا فإن
البروفات أيضًا حتى قبل
إطلاق النار فعليًا ، اعرف متى سيتم إطلاق البندقية ،
تأكد من
أنها تعمل بشكل صحيح ،
كل أنواع الأشياء من هذا القبيل
تجعلها آمنة قدر الإمكان